this pandemic and its fallout really
represents the biggest shock
to the u.s economy in living memory 2020
has been a turbulent year for the stock
market
the biggest drop we've seen since that
crash in 1987.
fourth quarter in 1999 that's the last
time that we saw
a quarter this good but rather than be
scared off by the dow's wild ride
millions of new investors many of whom
are bored
isolated and out of work because of the
pandemic are buying
like never before 2020 has been a banner
year for all brokerage firms
but the broker of the moment is robin
hood named after the fictional character
who robbed the rich to feed the poor
robin hood's founders say they created
the platform to democratize america's
financial system by making it cheaper
and easier
for a new generation of investors to
begin building their wealth
in the stock market i bet he's investing
right now
he's taking charge he's grabbing the
bull by the horns
since it was founded in 2013 the silicon
valley-based firm
has tried to disrupt the industry on
robin hood
traders can buy small slices of a stock
otherwise known as a fractional share
robin hood also doesn't require a
minimum balance for opening an account
but the perk that the company is most
known for is free trades
you ever think about trading stocks
there's always been a cost
usually up to 10 bucks for every single
trade
until now today free trades are the
industry standard
but that wasn't the case until last year
when robin hood's success
spurred established industry brokers
including charles schwab
e-trade and td ameritrade to eliminate
their commissions
free trades were partially what
attracted will nelson to the app
but what really sucked him in was the
intuitive interface
it was fairly easy from the get-go
nelson who has no background in finance
started using robinhood in 2018.
go into the search bar you type in what
you want
there it is there's the buy button how
many do you want
it's fairly straightforward that recipe
of easy to use interface
and free trades has transformed
robinhood into something of a phenomenon
this year the company reported 3 million
new accounts
bringing its total to 13 million all of
this attention has made robinhood
one of the most valuable startups in the
country but it has also drawn criticism
i fundamentally believe that decisions
belong to their owners so long as those
decisions were entered into
knowingly and willingly tara falcone is
a personal financial advisor
whose company rise up specializes in
working with millennials
and i think that that's where the fine
line is really being drawn here
is that these young inexperienced
traders don't know what they're doing
they've never received education around
investing most of them have no idea
what a stock even is or what its price
represents
in a statement to the wall street
journal a robin hood spokesperson wrote
it's not lost upon us that our company
and our service have become synonymous
with retail investing in america and
that this has led to millions of new
investors making their first investments
through robin hood we recognize this
profound responsibility
and we don't take it lightly in june
a 20 year old trader died by suicide
after he misinterpreted
his robin hood account statement which
temporarily showed a negative balance of
about seven hundred and thirty thousand
dollars
his family said he was trading options a
complicated financial instrument
typically used by experienced traders
i likened it like to giving the keys of
a sports car to a 12 year old
because you know there are certain
aspects um or actions in our society
that are gated
by age because of where we are as
young people in our kind of fundamental
psychological development
in a final note left for his family
which was later tweeted by his relative
kearns wrote that he had no clue what he
was doing and that he never intended
to take this much risk in a blog post on
robinhood's website
the company's co-founders wrote that
they were personally devastated by this
tragedy
robin hood said it now provides
investors with more educational
resources and customer support
the critics say robinhood still makes it
too easy for inexperienced individuals
to trade
robin hood still has fewer hurdles for
options trading than other brokers
i'm going to open up the robin hood app
i'm going to hit the magnifying glass at
the bottom
it takes me to browse i'm going to type
in
the ticker symbol nelson has been
trading options on robin hood
for about a year now then the next thing
i want to do is i want to hit
trade i see an option to buy or trade
options i'm going to click
trade options pulls it up
in just a few minutes with just a few
clicks he makes his trade
hit review gives you a chance to make
any edits before you execute
swipe up to submit
and the order was filled
so it really is that simple to execute
an
options trade on robinhood
to learn more about the world of finance
robin hood traders often turn to social
media
nelson taught himself about options
partially by watching youtube tutorials
others turn to popular forms on reddit
or facebook
i think what's happening in the options
realm right now with young people is
that
it's talked up so much more on social
media
as this like get rich quick scheme jose
duenas
is a moderator on the facebook group
robin hood stock traders
which has over a hundred thousand
members so i i joined
and then i immediately saw things that
were kind of worrying you know people
just
throwing money into a stock duinas who
is a self-taught trader
felt an obligation to try and help you
feel like or at least i felt
that i had some type of responsibility
towards these people i'm like okay maybe
i know a little bit more than the
average person
let me try to educate some of these
people
earlier this year hertz filed for
bankruptcy and its stock price crashed
whereas established traders stayed away
robin hood's traders
invested in record numbers so a stock
that had you know over the last year or
so really traded kind of in the teens
they're now seeing it in like the one
dollar and change range
and thinking oh my god this is the steal
of the century of quartz hurts is going
to continue to exist in some form i
better own this
this strategy has been repeated many
times with robin hood traders jumping on
high risk investments
like the airlines in kodak
robinhood's app has also been described
as gamified
robinhood has different levels that you
can unlock as you start trading
a level one is usually just buying and
selling stocks
and then level two i believe is options
trading option three is a more advanced
method they say
but they do make it seem like you unlock
more
the more you learn so it is a kind of a
video game aspect
i've never seen another brokerage
account uh as
colorful and exciting as the robin hood
trading app there's confetti that
appears the first time you place a trade
and while that is something to celebrate
i think that confetti
uh denotes a bit more of a you know idea
of celebration then maybe
is warranted despite the potential
pitfalls both nelson
and duenas say they'll continue to use
the app i kind of do see it as a
stepping stone you know i'm young i'm
24 years old i think it is a good
platform to get your feet wet maybe
learn a little
something about stocks but for serious
investing i don't think robin hood
is considered or should be considered a
serious stock broker
and i think there is value into
making accessible platforms for people
who don't have
you know twenty a thousand twenty
thousand dollars or hundreds of
thousands
or millions of dollars to go approach a
hedge fund or
to get a special broker and have these
fees
i think it's very important to kind of
increase access to it because that's
part of the
long-term way we i don't know make
society more equitable
you